[Música]
voy a haceros dos preguntas tenéis que
levantar la mano si estáis de acuerdo la
primera sería cuántos de vosotros creéis
que con esta moto se pueden hacer viajes
largos de más de 10.000 km
bueno esto tiene truco porque con tantas
pegatinas estoy dando pistas la segunda
pregunta es un poco más profunda cuántos
de vosotros creéis que rodando en esta
moto se puede cambiar el mundo aunque
sea un poquito
no está mal no está mal bueno se acabó
el examen y en este rato vamos a pasar
juntos a explicar las claves de cómo con
una moto tan sencilla como esta una
causa solidaria y mucha pasión se puede
cambiar el mundo a mejor pero antes de
nada me presento yo soy el chófer texto
que está aquí que es capaz de llevarme a
los lugares más lejanos inhóspitos e
increíbles sin ningún tipo de apoyo
logístico
y en condiciones muchas veces extremas
para una moto que está concebida para
rodar en la ciudad y no para meterla en
los berenjenales que vais a ver donde la
meto pero cambiar el mundo no es el
único objetivo de mis viajes solidarios
esta tarde aquí mi objetivo va más allá
y me encantaría que con la historia que
van a contar descubrir si es cuál es
vuestra pasión no sé pues toca el piano
cantar escribir jugar a lolo al clash
royale
correr maratones y como esta pasión
podeis convertirla en energía
colaborativa que ayude a los demás lo
llevo desde los 14 años montando moto
detenido motos pequeñas medianas grandes
con todas me la he pasado fenomenal pero
desde hace cinco años ruedo en esta que
tenéis aquí y con ella voy a trabajar
agorreca os salgo los fin de semana con
mis amigos hago la compra incluso me he
venido desde pamplona hasta aquí para
dar la charla rodando en la vespa y
mañana regresaré otra vez no
esta es esta moto es además de hacerme
todo esto también hago viajes solidarios
viajes tres viajes solidarios ya que no
sabes cuántos kilómetros tiene estables
para pues tiene 300.000 km
300.000 km tiene
mi primer viaje solidario fue a cabo
norte cabo norte es es el punto más
septentrional de todo el continente
europeo está a 500 kilómetros por encima
del círculo polar ártico
por encima de cabo norte tiene es mar y
el polo norte vale él la causa solidaria
que fue unida a este viaje fue la de las
enfermedades tropicales la malaria el
chagas la brucelosis leishmaniasis
enfermedades que matan todos los años a
millones de niños en todo el mundo
principalmente en países en vías de
desarrollo porque los laboratorios no
investigan sufriendo destinan los
recursos suficientes para conseguir los
fármacos porque pues porque los
pacientes estas patologías no tienen
dinero para pagar estos medicamentos
entonces por eso me pareció muy
interesante unir mis viajes a esta causa
el viaje duró 20 días fue en enero de
2017 fueron 12.000 km 4000 kilómetros
fueron sobre hielo
las etapas fueron de 500 600 kilómetros
al día sin días de descanso y con
temperaturas medias del orden de 30
grados bajo cero y dos días tuvimos
menos 40 grados a esas temperaturas uno
ya no siente frío sino lo que siente una
especie de dolor que te invade el cuerpo
y los huesos realmente es una
experiencia nada aconsejable
a esas temperaturas tuve que gestionar
cuatro caídas y cinco pinchazos
a cabo norte en invierno y sin apoyo
logístico nunca se había llegado con una
moto como ésta a pesar de haber habido
varios intentos pero que nunca lo
lograron sin embargo con moto grande
tipo trail fueron 5 las motos que
llegaron pero con la diferencia de que
esas motos lo hicieron a final de
febrero y en marzo y eso qué significa
pues que rodaron todas las etapas con
luz de día nosotros lo hicimos
a primeros de enero y eso significó que
rodábamos a oscuras por eso todos los
focos que lleva a la vespa
y me diréis y por qué fuistes en enero
en vez de ir en febrero en marzo con luz
menos peligroso podéis disfrutar del
paisaje por hacerlos más valientes los
más listos los más duros del barrio en
absoluto si fuimos en enero es por qué
yo trabajo y tengo que las vacaciones
que tengo y aprovechaba vacaciones de
navidad de manera que con unos poquitos
días más hacia todo el viaje y es que si
queremos cambiar el mundo tenemos que
hacerlo en nuestras condiciones normales
habituales no hacer cosas
extraordinarias y no utilizar los medios
que tenemos y las capacidades que
tenemos
la preparación de este viaje sin embargo
duró un año el año anterior en 2016 me
fui también a
a noruega para rodar en invierno con
ruedas de clavos conocer la técnica de
la conducción en sobre hielo testar los
los materiales la ropa la propia moto a
ver si aguantaba esas temperaturas
bueno pues lo que es preparación del
viaje no está esta preparación
del viaje y todo lo que ello conlleva y
los sufrimientos y los inconvenientes
del viaje lo que disfrutas en ello no
significa que todo sea de color de rosa
de hecho las condiciones de vida fueron
bastante espartanas en el viaje nos
levantaron muy temprano a las cinco y
media de la mañana
desayunábamos algo caliente y a las
siete estábamos rodando
y el resto del día nos alimentamos de
barritas energéticas que comprábamos en
las gasolineras que teníamos en el
camino cuando paramos a [ __ ] gasolina
como es la de la imagen
en este viaje perdí 8 kilos en 20 días 8
kilos de manera que si alguien está
interesado en conocer un método eficaz
de operación bikini le puedo sugerir que
haga que haga un viaje de estos
el estrés el estrés es uno de los
factores en este viaje con los que tuve
que convivir convivir todos los días y
las 10 11 horas que iba montado en la
moto cada día
vamos a ver las carreteras tienen una
capa de hielo de este groso de varios
centímetros y que es peinada por las
máquinas quitanieves que peinan que
literalmente para formar unos surcos
longitudinales para que los coches no se
salgan de la calzada pues esto que va
muy bien a los coches a las motos les
baja tan porque tú vas así y con los
suplementarias se van moviendo imaginaos
de noche con los focos y así no los vas
así y qué pasa que de repente te
adelanta un camión que lleva no una
gabarra sino dos o tres gabarras vale
tres guevara son los remolques que
llevan muy largos y te lanzan una
cortina de trozos de hielo de nieve de
sal incluso de gravilla que utilizan
para compactar el hielo y que si te dan
en la pantalla la pueden romperte se
acaba el viaje después tiene un
accidente de tren tiene ira clara así
cuando te crees que te van a adelantar
tuerce es miras por el ojillo
pero atención esta mano tiene que ir
limpiando la pantalla para poder ver
nosotros vas con una mano mientras te va
adelantando un camión por una carretera
que no tiene arcén porque es una pared
de una pared de hielo entonces este
estrés disminuye cuando ya vas avanzando
hacia arriba donde haga finlandia pues
de rovaniemi ya no hay apenas tráfico y
eso te permite disfrutar un poco más del
viaje y aprovechar las pocas horas que
tienes de día pues para incluso pararte
como es en este caso a charlar con un
tapón
esto es en la zona de laponia estaba por
allí cazando y entonces pare le pregunté
qué hacía su familia le expliqué mi
proyecto y yo noté que me miraba algo
raro como si tuviera viendo un
extraterrestre y un momento determinado
pensé que igual tiene razón igual tiene
razón y esto me sugería una reflexión
que ahora os traslado y es que la zona
de la cordura que es la que
habitualmente nos movemos la zona de la
cordura está íntimamente pegada a la
zona de la locura hay una línea muy fina
las dos puedo asegurar el 95% de mi
tiempo me lo paso en la zona de la
cordura lo que ocurre es que ese otro 5%
se nota mucho se ve mucho y es lo que
hace que tenga una fama del loco de la
vespa cosa que por otro lado me trae al
pairo y que sí que lo justifico y que
digamos por el todo lo que se consigue
de apoyo con esta locura a las causas a
las causas solidarias
la llegada a cabo norte fue un viernes
13 de enero de 2017 aquí estoy con mi
compañero david campo es un tipo
sensacional lo mejor del viaje fue ir
con esta persona que no pudo venir en
los siguientes pero ya os digo que es lo
mejor de lo mejor de lo mejor como
compañero como os decía
llegamos a la bola del cabo norte el fin
del mundo hacia un frío que pelaba un
viento te imaginas ahí está y resulta
que delante de eso tienes un edificio
turístico con salas de cine restaurante
y tienda de souvenirs y además estaba
llena de chinos con sus cámaras yo pero
esto que es todo lo que hemos estado de
verdad aquí al fin del mundo llegamos y
está esto esto qué es esto es como si
los primeros astronautas cuando llegaron
a la luna se hubieran encontrado con un
mcdonald's allí y dice estas pequeñas
depres que te entran cuando te pasa esto
las conviertes en algo positivo y como
bueno pues nos metimos dentro nos
calentamos un poco para iniciar ya para
iniciar la el regreso después de este
viaje de cabo norte vinieron más viajes
este es una imagen de
a dakar en esta ocasión sí solo no me
acompaña mi amigo fueron 10.000 km
no estuvo exento de anécdotas algunas
delicadas como que tenga que tienen que
ver con la ciudad personal en concreto
en mauritania verdad que al final no
pasó nada pero que el hecho de ir solo
eres un objetivo muy muy claro para toda
esta gente
la causa solidaria aquí también fueron
las enfermedades tropicales
el siguiente viaje que fue el verano
pasado fue a mongolia mongolia fueron 26
mil kilómetros en la vespa también en
solitario la causa solidaria fue el
apoyo a un hospital que está en el congo
y que se dedica también a tratar
enfermedades tropicales pacientes allí
in situ este viaje tuvo otras
connotaciones relacionadas con problemas
con la moto mecánicos allí no no hay
recambio note la regla que no conocen y
tuve que arreglar a yo bueno fin al
final resultó bien ahora no es nada
aconsejable ir a mongolia en esta moto
eso ya os lo digo vale y el siguiente
viaje el siguiente viaje es en invierno
esa vida con quedarás con este nombre
con viacom ya con esta al norte de
siberia serían 25 mil kilómetros ida y
vuelta
el pueblo es el pueblo habitado más frío
del planeta tiene el récord de menos 72
grados centígrados aunque la media la
media son menos 50 es una habilidad
menos 50 grados que menos 50 grados que
a 40 kilómetros por hora te vas a una
sensación térmica cercana a los menos
100 grados que es una temperatura
lateral que hay en la corteza de marte
entonces yo no sé qué va a pasar no sé
si la moto va a aguantar yo creo que sí
aunque bueno ahora hay materiales de
todo tipo tal
quedaros con esto no será el próximo
invierno y la causa solidaria va a ser
la investigación en la leucemia infantil
bien todos estos proyectos todos estos
viajes no hubieran tenido la repercusión
que han tenido si no tuviese un buen
equipo de comunicación que es lo que
tengo detrás y que consiguieron más de
37 millones de audiencias encontrar
redes sociales con su trabajo entonces
esto también tiene su su visión de la
vida normal para sacar adelante
cualquier cosa cualquier proyecto no hay
que ir solo hay que rodearse de gente y
de gente mejor que uno
eso es el consejo que me dieron en su
día un buen profesor y la verdad es que
lo he procurado seguir y para este caso
en el caso de estos viajes unidades pues
me ha venido me ha venido al pelo
hay un amigo mío carlos andreu que en
sus charlas dice que la felicidad no
está en llegar en el destino en la meta
sino en él mientras en el durante en lo
que ocurre en medio y tiene muchísima
razón en estos viajes lo más importante
lo que más me llena es el contacto con
la gente
el pararme el que te cuenten cómo es su
vida cuáles son sus aspiraciones
todo eso te cambia la vida te cambia la
vida y luego llegas y no te quejas de
nada porque ves cómo vive esta gente en
muchos de estos países y cómo vives tú
de que me quejo de que me quejo pues
estos chavales sonrientes no tienen nada
nada pero nada nada de nada no tienen ni
zapatos de nada y viven felices yo te
hace pensar no te hace pensar y
recapacitar
amigos
estoy seguro absolutamente seguro que
aquí hay más de 400 ideas de cómo
cambiar el mundo con una pasión
descubrir cuál es vuestra pasión depende
de vosotros tenéis que atrevernos a
mirar os tenéis que tener la curiosidad
de observar o sí de ver eso cuál es
vuestra pasión y cómo con ella podéis
hacer un mundo mejor ha sido un placer
haber compartido esta presente
experiencia con vosotros muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero no